welcome to the fword and in case you're
wondering what the f stands for it's
food of
course I've taken over this restaurant
and for the next 9 weeks I'll be cooking
seasonal three course meals for 60
invited diners I've adapted my
restaurant recipes so that everything I
cook here is something you can cook at
home between now and Christmas we're
going to eat drink talk food if it's on
your plate in your fridge or in your
Supermarket it will be
here and C my mother and I C my dad then
I love my mother and I love my dad what
to have all if I never had any effort
the my mother and CR my dad I love my
mother and I love my dad want to have
all
[Applause]
never right s ready y let's go yes and I
want the P nicely colored Ronnie yes yes
Gordon let's go Greg taste everything
and we're working together aren't we
well doesn't look like it does
it this Saturday sees the launch of the
national vegan week and in order to help
celebrate we're doing the amazing
starter of lentils cooked with carrots
leaks and sarec finished with a slab of
fog also on the menu tonight a fantastic
herb crusted racka lamp that you can
make this
weekend just 59 days to go meet the
F-word restaurant's Christmas dinner
Anthony BL over the stone oh no and I
filled the place with women to launch my
campaign to get women back in the
kitchen amongst the diners is Marty
McCutchen who can't even boil an egg I
don't have um SAU spin or frying pants I
don't own one and I've got paper ples
cuz then I can just Chuck it in the B I
don't have to wash
it let's go let's go let's go quick now
Fara can be duck liver or Goose liver
this is actually duck liver and it
actually looks like a sort of block of
butter but you get it really nice and
crispy on the siid and inside it should
be served slightly pink but you got to
be quick if you leaving the pan too long
it disappears let's
go most people would never think of
cooking faga but it's so simple don't
leave it to the restaurant chefs try it
at home it's easier than frying an egg
good more salt in there please come on
taste it first of all let me show you
don't worry about starting with oil you
know that because paga is 90% what fat
fat so why are you putting fat in the
pan um stupid stupidly which piece of
that would you put in first um the
biggest why cuz it takes longer to cook
good second biggest third biggest and
smallest in right now we take it off the
heat yeah there's enough heat in there
to still color
it tilt the pan helps cook the back of
the fager yes back on the heat and turn
it around
again look at the difference in color
now through there now it's starting to
break down and tilt the pan back up and
then just just a little glaze
over yeah nicely and they should all
come out evenly yes turn them around
again carefully yes I'm serving the faga
on a bed of P lentils don't use red
lentils as they'll turn to Mush they
cook together with what we call a brins
that's finely chopped vegetables that
have been sauteed then I bind the whole
thing together with a fragrant herb
vinegarette fer on the lentils let's go
are you happy with those yes sir wipe
the
plates go send it second time Matthew
table
five faga excites a lot of passion
because some people think it's cruel but
I think it's delicious and you should
try everything at least once I was a
fagra virgin before I came here and I
really wanted to try it so definitely
definitely a good choice it tastes like
butter it tastes like the most delicious
velvety buttery creamy deliciousness
that just slivers down your throat it's
most fabulous taste in your mouth and
it's slightly crispy but then inside
it's all just like velvet stroking you
inside your mouth it's delicious well I
thought I thought the starting was quite
nice actually really lovely nice and
smooth work toward the vegetables um and
it's something that I couldn't possibly
cook myself really I heard the girl on
the next table say oh I'm not eating
that so we kind of had a word with our
waiter who negotiated that that plate
came over here as well
hello how are you I'm good you well yeah
really well thank you very much enjoy
the plog yeah lovely really nice plog so
how many times a week would you eat out
normally well I eat out loads because I
can't I can't cook to save my life I've
probably got a few crackers and some
crunchy uput conflex in the cupboard mom
must have taught you how to cook
somewhere along the line no um well she
tried but she kind of gave up with me um
when I was about 22 she got me a walk I
said you can't go wrong you should check
everything in and cook it and um I
cooked fish with vegetables and I didn't
cut the the fish properly and I was sick
for about 12 days and since then I've
just I was so U and I can't do it again
so before eating out rather than cooking
got yeah especially got someone like you
cooking for me why how can I compete
with that and Main Course Raam oh lovely
potatoes cett provinal Tomatoes herbs
light vinegar again um I'll be back
after that please eat it all don't will
in fact the only thing I want you to
leave yeah are the bones you know what
you're the man of my dream you're the
first man who told me to make sure I eat
it all clean played I've never had that
problem enjoy your lamb I will pink
medium well done um for me well done no
chance
pink oh no I've got to eat raw meat
now oh dear Mr Corin Gordon another day
another meal yep another day another
meal do you ever feel guilty going out
to eat for a living I never feel guilty
about anything at all and I wonder what
it' be like to actually be a food critic
sort of 365 days a year unimaginably
good so much better than being a chef I
can't tell you listen Before Christmas
it's really important I would love to
have a food critic in the kitchen just
to show you an insight to what it's like
doing a full day's work and being up at
6:00 in the morning that's like saying
that's like saying to a policeman I'd
like you to spend a day in prison I know
it's bad in there that's why I'm not in
there as a Critic what do you think of
the stter I've had better but then I
have I have so much it's a great piece
of farra you know it's it's they're from
they're from nice Ducks aren't they yeah
they're Hungarian yeah but in terms of
but in terms of the provence of it it's
nice to know at least that it came from
uh I'm quite nutty about that sort of
thing there is a rumor okay that you
went into a restaurant once and actually
asked the name of the pig before you at
it yes I have done that but really the
name of the farm will do and even though
you you laugh at me you you're more and
more into this you've got something
going on at home which is fairly sort of
huly witching sto style Haven you I mean
I live in the city I want my children to
learn and understand where their food
comes
from what's this for for the turkeys to
live in that's right and why have they
got so much space CU so they can run
around run around and get what get
exercise exercise exactly get fat and
get exercise surprise surprise Gordon's
have one of his fantastic ideas which
I'm not exactly over the moon about he's
decided that we are going to grow
Christmas lunch he wants to make the
children understand that Christmas lunch
you know actually comes from somewhere
not just from the supermarket so we're
going to fatten up the turkeys and grow
our own vegetables but me I think you
going get really attached to them you
know
[Applause]
that Holly they'll be tough old birds
[Music]
yeah I want to hear the noise though no
Lou
[Music]
Lily pie go quick jump on come on quick
jump and again jump and again
jump they've got to be in this pen and
we got to keep them away from the foxes
okay we got a problem in this setting
with foxies because there's a lot of
them around there's woods behind um what
we're going to do is enclose everything
with wire chicken wire and we're going
to bury that into the ground 18 in who's
going to help me me
me
my once perfect garden that I've spent
all summer having landscape gardeners is
now going to be
[Music]
ruined if you're
naughty you're sleeping out here with
the turkeys as well yes yes
okay you understand why we're here don't
you yeah we're going to choose six of
these birds to take home okay to fat
for
Christmas are you hungry would you like
to eat one we have both bronze and white
turkeys they're all free range so
there's very little difference in it the
bronze are just a little bit gamier in
flavor and it's just personal preference
really Chris need six turkeys for
Christmas the idea of bring them here
today was to sort of give them a sense
of where they come from to make them
understand that Christmas day isn't just
coming out of the supermarket Jack have
you caught one yet come on we've got
4,000 turkeys here on this Farm yeah so
how old are they these are 16 weeks old
these and they go right up to 24 these
will be about 24 weeks what's the
difference in we we we'll sell the
bronze turkeys from about 7 or8 of ready
right up to sort of
30 okay three
more you've
[Music]
got
thank turkeys need a diet which is rich
in cereals and so we put at least 70%
wheat barley oats into the diet and that
gives us a lovely finish and and that
gives you a marvelous Christmas
[Music]
L chy Daddy's driving they're shoting
themselves there hold on then welcome
him home now we have to think of some
names for them and I thought okay
because there's six of them okay we got
one each okay we'll name them after
chefs
okay yes yours is called Gary that's the
one with a spiky Bumm Gary
Gary yours walks a bit funny so we'll
call him
[Music]
Jamie oh no look there it is the stubble
one down the end the one who wants to be
on the lonely Bird that's
deia what's yours called Lily pie
Anthony Anthony that's right the little
dumpy one like
you oh Jack look after
Nigella this is the real sort of happy
chirpy chappie with a big neck we'll
call him
asley Lily Lily why don't we take them
through and just show them the oven very
quickly no
no open the door no no help Daddy
no yes he fit in he'll fit in right
listen listen listen listen listen
listen we got to roast him soon
[Applause]
Daddy Anthony all over the stone oh
no and just check his underneath there
look right put him in the bed now please
come on Anthony move your
ass
jie that's right do you want a little
kiss on the breast all right ask you're
asking right come on say good night
night
night hi Chris hi how you doing I'm fine
love you m you good good good that's
slightly different from eating turkey
however yeah but there you I have got to
S just make sure my turkeys are fine
with you I can guarantee that the
turkeys are in fine order getting very
plump and everywhere just just
just just put it down to experience you
know where there's but there's money any
tips that you may have that I could pick
up on to sort of I suppose make them
feel a little bit more at home just make
sure they got plenty of room got plenty
of food water and you let them in and
out each day on time okay right and
maybe give them a bit more grassp when
they've eaten off all the grass of that
little pen you got them in give them
more grass it's worth it so nigella's
plump breasts are going to taste a lot
better than more grass than my back
Garden she eats all so
yeah next on the menu rack of lamb and
this boat thinks his dessert is better
than mine but he has got more hair than
brains would you like to be a proper
Chef one day oh God no what would put
you off for hours you
mate I'm scared and I teach Marty
McCutchen how to sharpen a knife I've
been doing everything like this would be
golden just like n and a half weeks
stay
welcome back to the FW the place that
you can find out everything you need to
know about food next up is the main
course season the corett yes fresh bzl
in there I'll open up and season it
let's go main course tonight is the
beautiful racka lamb Ser with the bler
potato and CTIC corett with tomato Prov
South and I never ever thought i' ever
say this I promise however here's one I
made
earlier racka lamb this is the
Rolls-Royce of lamb it is every Chef's
dream to cook
this
in kitchens especially in my kitchens we
always season on plays because we don't
want to waste any salt pepper so once
we've seasoned from a height we then get
the rack of lamb and almost sort of rub
it in and let the lamb absorb all that
salt and pepper so we're wasting
nothing hot pan olive
oil it's simple mathematics no color no
flavor get some color on there
[Music]
skinside down hot oven 7 to 8
minutes herb
[Music]
[Applause]
crust I just picked some parsley in
parsley Ros me
time that parsley gives it a really nice
dark green color great parmesan and
seasoned
[Music]
and then just a drizzle of olive oil to
bring it
together Blitz
[Applause]
it comes out
[Music]
amazing firm with the spring and it will
be cooked perfectly
pink djon mustard
whilst it's hot the sort of mustard
absorbs and melts quickly into the fat
and just makes it a lot more
flavorsome and it's almost like sort of
dipping your LLY in with
[Music]
sherbet crisp the breadcrumbs 3 to 4
minutes onto the plate her crusted rack
of lamb
done right how long for the
lamb let's go I want it together yes
five and five yeah let's go I'm joined
by a handpicked kitchen Brigade over
there is Ronnie he's been with me now in
three years quite a delicate touch and a
bloody good cook Greg this guy used to
be a Management Consultant until he saw
the pilot light and he cooks as if he's
been in the kitchen 20 many years he's
only been in trade 3 years and every
Chef has a right-and man and my rightand
man is sge he's been by my side now for
close to 10 years the other two Cooks in
the kitchen who look absolutely
petrified are our trainees we call them
commies Matthew's a 20-year-old waiter
who's desperate to make the step into
the kitchen Miller is 24 and works in
corporate Hospitality she's passionate
about food but can she handle being
bossed about move your ass neither of
them has worked in a professional
kitchen before with the l we're serving
a bonger potato the most important thing
about this particular potato is like a
layered cake got these wonderful
caramelized onions potatoes onions
potatoes onions and then it's cooked
with a really nice stock so it acts with
a bit of a sauce perfect for this time
of year and perfect with a
lamb lamb please buer potatoes are easy
to cook but look sophisticated and are
absolutely delicious simply fine sliced
potatoes and lay them in a dish with
soed onions season between the layers
and pour some chicken stock over the top
into the oven for 15 minutes and that's
it it like do and Wass but if anything
healthier and
easier let's go Ronnie lamb in 4 minutes
on the hot plate Y at serving with the
lamb we've got the sort of soed corett
with tomato like Prof C finished with a
little bit of B vinegar cett are very
difficult vegetable to cook because a
lot of people don't cook them enough so
therefore they're get a little bit slimy
but soing them in olive oil beautifully
done with salt pepper finished with a
tablespoon of B vinegar it's a really
nice way of eating them just smell that
now in front there smell in there
yes okay how long for the first lamb two
and a half please Gordon how
long no come on yeah know I said I
started already I said both five and
five come on let's go then yes two and a
half right I want two pans done at any
one
time God don't send anything yet
yes come on
Matthew how long in that lamb never
thought i' to say that no no no listen
don't come here hey I'm helping you yeah
yeah don't take the P out of me I'm
helping you so what the you shouting at
me how long the L are you that stupid so
I'm here to help you and now you're
shouting at me how long the lamb slice
the lamp yeah do it yourself sorry
Chef let's go
Miller stupid pull the plates in towards
you so you can see them all the way
around shake the bottle Miller shake the
bottle why are we shaking it Miller um
to make sure it's multiplied so exactly
so it's evenly distributed come on let's
go right let's go come on yes come on
Matthew start sending start sending
Matthew clean your plates come on come
on come on come on six on five Miller
yes Matthew 6 on 15 yes check what
you're doing
go I got six on 15 please let's go so to
follow R of lamp and it's enormous
fantastic
thank let's go what with both hands
Matthew speed up ladies how we doing
yeah good to see I'd like to see with
bone in your mouth happy very happy yes
good I thought it was lovely the lamb
was cooked to Perfection I love the lamb
pink you going to finish that yes I am
yeah I'll get upset if you don't finish
it you know that how many glasses of
wine have you had quite a lot quite a
lot fantastic yes good to see you I was
vegetarian until 2 weeks ago and I'm
converted 110% now I did think it was a
bit pink but it's the taste is just
fantastic absolutely fantastic laughing
and singing hello oh no you devoured it
you finished it do you know what I loved
it I've never had lamb rare before I've
always been a bit scared of the blood
but I love this it's nice not too much
blood oozing out no and this time of
year Autumn has to be the perfect time
um you said you don't cook at home you
must sort of cook something um a I don't
know I do no I do do um toast and I do
um scrambled eggs in a microwave you put
it I put a little bit of butter and a
bit of sea salt in cuz it makes me feel
like a chef you cook scrambled egg yeah
in a microwave yeah I don't have um SAU
spins or frying pant I don't I one and
I've got paper plates cuz then I can
just chck it in the bin I don't have to
wash it beautiful kitchen nothing in
there no plates nothing microwave to
cook scrambled EG in you got any knives
in the kitchen uh couple of normal ones
yeah I'm going to borrow you just for 2
minutes I'm going to show you something
absolutely crucial in the kitchen no no
no no no no don't worry about that now
just for 2 minutes now um the most
important thing about being in the
kitchen yeah okay is um learning okay to
sharpen a knife Goosebump oh Goosebumps
where there they're absolutely fine um
right okay what's that called uh uh uh
that's a that's a that's not something
you measure rings on don't know measure
rings in the
Jewelers oh that's a steel okay so
we hold the steel there left hand and
you sharpen a knife that way you can cut
your vegetables nice and thin you can
cut your meat nice and thin you can
slice your fish right left hand or
right-handed I'm right-handed yeah okay
so that's my left hand hold that in that
hand that right just nice and slowly
bend the wrist and show some flexibility
on the wrist there you go nice and slow
be careful you don't cut yourself there
you go I never thought I'd be doing
anything like this with you golden just
like N9 and a half weeks there you go
now bend that wrist it's too stiff the
wrist so you left hand right hand in I'm
scared that's why what's my wrist
there's no flexibility in that wrist
there now you no no no Grace it nice
nice big long strokes nice big long
strokes of the knife and there you go
close your eyes there go there you go
now there go May to close my eyes yeah
no because you just listen to the noise
hear the noise
yes there we go bit Rhythm look there
you go that nice there you go okay so
now you know how to sharpen knife is
there anything else you want me to do
for
now no yay I can go back there you go
Jesus Christ scary
okay five lamb
yes oh I thought oh God he's going to
get me to cut carrots really quickly
with his knife I can just feel it he
said that my wrist was too stiff he
probably would relaxed that's I said I
was scared that's he was sort of a bit
of an innuendo with it and I thought I'm
not happy about that that would do me no
good whatsoever your concentration Fe oh
I know but he said close your eyes I
thought oh God what's he going to do to
me I've got a knife in my hand that's a
braak man to ask me to have a knife and
sharpen it with my eyes closed yeah
that's a brave man golden Ramsey you're
a brave
man goodness gracious I'm
[Applause]
shaking how's it going mate um how's the
lamp absolutely fantastic really really
good a very manly dish and I noticed
that you've got a almost exclusively
women in the restaurant tonight is this
you're trying to set me up with somebody
or what's up I'm launching a campaign
pain to get women back in the kitchen oh
you dog do you think they want to go
there no you know what I'm fed up with
the customers coming into the kitchen
90% of them now they're all cooking at
home they're male I'm amazed though you
commissioned that you actually went to
the length of commissioning a a survey
to prove your your point and this proved
appar that 3/4s of women who can't cook
uh it's not that they can't they can't
cook and they don't care they can't they
regret it I'm personally going on a
mission now to invite every woman in the
country okay to get me in their kitchen
I'm going to offer my services to the
women of Britain starting tonight excuse
me sir our survey showed that more men
than women find cooking a pleasure while
more women believe it's a chore I've
been out and about across the country
and I've been shocked by what I've found
and look brand new pan never been used
before the place is more set out like a
cocktail bar as opposed to a kitchen
over the next N9 weeks I'm going to be
helping women across the country to get
back in their kitchens why can't you
cook I am a bit clumsy I know how to do
it I know you're supposed to do that I
poisoned my best friend oh
dear from steak and chips to Sunday
roast they'll discover the pleasure of
cooking for their friends their families
and
themselves smells fantastic it does it
never smells like this and in return I
want to promise that each woman will say
goodbye for good to meals of charday and
crisps how many tins of baked beans have
you got and hello to Fantastic
homecooked food I've never had that many
people sat around my table for bad
around ofuse mommy yeah thank you m
thank you
m hey tell the neighbors the kitchen's
being
used the kitchen's being
used right well Gordon reckons there
must be millions of women in Britain who
can't cook and so he plans between now
and Christmas to get as many of them as
he can back in the kitchen so he's asked
me to tell you that if you're a woman
and you can't cook and you think he
could help get in touch with us via the
website better still if you're a man and
you've got a daughter or a wife or a
sister who can't cook let us know and
we'll see if we can't do you a favor and
I tell you what if you can cook get in
touch with this anyway especially if
you're single put my name on it maybe in
close a photograph friends the
production the people now the people I
can yeah you're right yeah hello enjoy
lamb I love my lamb enjoy the follow off
fabulous when was the last time you
cooked in the kitchen um oh at the
weekend at the weekend yeah D when was
the last time you cooked in the kitchen
a month ago a month ago CJ yeah my
campaign to get women back further back
further back than that to get women back
in the kitchen um um The Campaign was
launched because over the last four or
five years 90% of the people come into
my kitchen yeah and fascinated about the
cooking I'm not the women they're sat at
the table having wine and cocktail but
that's because the men have got time to
come into you know you can spend 24
hours marinading a girin but women have
got other things've got the kids we've
got the housework you do the housework
when did
you men have fall in love with the
kitchens women are falling out of love
with their kitchens well these two are
too young but us two we were the
generation good argument now you know
that no we were the generation we were
told we would be having it all we're not
having it all we're doing it all and we
haven't got time to go in the kitchen
and PS about marinading something for 24
hours the only reason you can do that is
because you've got a lovely wife who's
at home with your guantan
turkeys in the garden come on Jane
you're yourself when was the last time
you cooked I haven't cooked for ages I
haven't got time I'm doing homework I'm
doing housework School runs I'm doing
work yes okay I'm doing all the things
that my husband do my grandmother cooked
because she loved cooking she did all
the things that you did without the and
without the Hoover anything else done
everything Jane just said but Jane's
saying now today's modern woman doesn't
have to cook because they're busy got
time robish I think that that one of the
art the art and the pride of being a
great cook is Mak making that time don't
go shopping yeah it's not spending 3 or
4 hours in the kitchen it's just cooking
less time with the nails less time with
the hair more time with the kitchen Jane
the nails can we look at the nails they
less time in the nails less time in the
hair more time in the kitchen Jane
rubbish busy busy see you dear oh
dear next on the menu it's pudding time
almur takes me on with his recipe for
bread butter pudding yeah sounds
disgusting it's not
disgusting J Corin goes in search of the
truth about the drunkard's favorite the
Donna Kebab the Donna Kebab turns out to
be a gouret
[Applause]
production welcome back to the FW now
it's dessert time and that means bread
and butter pudding and the reason why it
is a bread and butter pudding because Al
Murray challenged me to make one better
than him each week on the F-word a guest
will attempt to beat me by making their
favorite dessert we'll each use our own
recipe for the same pudding and a panel
of blind taster will choose their
favorite the winning dessert will be
served to the restaurant
diners bring it on cojak you haven't got
a hope right uh Mr Murray you really
think you can cook better than me oh
yeah Gordon you're having a laugh aren't
you no no no this is you know dead
simple this the whole the whole Murray
food philosophy simple keep it simple
stupid okay so it's a thick cut loaf
currents yeah bit of milk yeah yeah
sounds disgusting is that it it's not
disgusting how many eggs you putting in
there three you tight
bastard in my bread and butter pudding
I'm going to use three whole eggs and
three egg yolk so it get really nice
rich delicious custard can you stop
watching me cuz I feel you're trying to
steal my recipe would you like to be a
proper Chef one day oh God
no no what would put you off the hours
you
mate what do you mean me well you know
clearly plays havoc with a person being
a chef I mean I've hung out with sge a
lot and he's not normal so what have you
done first tell me well I've done the
bread I've buttered the pan you have to
butter the pan children butter the pan
or it won't come off the pan when you're
washing it up what are you flavoring
your Custard
with well sugar and lemon no alcohol no
alcohol no are you putting alcohol in
yours do you know it's sort of autumn so
I'm going to put a little bit of
Bailey's cream in there that's classy
you know what ladies like when they love
Bailey's and eyes it's a fruit based
drink for the lady
yeah you know and do you know what it
just makes that a little bit moish yeah
yeah yeah I believe you you see my
baguettes are 24 hours old are they yes
that's what I'd heard so because the
drier they are Yeah the more custard
they ABS more custard they absorb yeah
like you've got big fat stodgy bread
it's not going to absorb any custard
it's going to like eating dry bread ow
you can't do that to our customers
they're your customers I'm not here next
week so what you put in the bottom of
your dish butter and then the bread and
then the bread on top buttered Bread on
top of the butter see I'm putting a
little bit of surprise at the bottom of
mine oh that's exciting let's have a
look let's have a look at what you're
actually doing here what's this dried
cranberries oh they're delicious aren
they AR just a relief I've got sutis cuz
it's exactly what I
need I know come on come on hey hey
that's unfair now tast that's good for
the urinary tract that is is it yeah it
is actually have you soaked these uh yes
are quite juicy just in hot water that's
all just to sort of rehydrate them a
little bit all
right so
anyway before I so rudely interrupted
get the custard right
which I didn't bother cooking right
there's no point it's going to cook in
the oven anyway right he's complicating
it again and you pour the Custard in on
top put the raisins on I've got some
raisins left you see this is how I cook
in a haphazard manoline G I defy anyone
to argue with my bread and butter
pudding okay whilst Al is making this
bread and butter sandwich full of
raisins what we've got here is um the
most amazing sort of soaked 24-hour old
baguette and it's done with a sort of
Bailey's Custard in between the layers
we've got sultanas golden raisins a
little bit of apricot jam and then we're
going to cover the top of that with
sugar so it caramelizes as it Cooks in
the oven and that's going to be 10 times
better than old cheffy over there that
tastes like stale bread that's been
dipped in ale and left outside for three
weeks and even the cat won't eat it okay
ready for the oven yeah absolutely yeah
here it
comes now just before goes in there just
just just have a look and even before
they're cooked yeah you know exactly
which one's going to come out best with
their blind tasters that one oh come on
now the normal one you know it's not
down to the appearance is it Down The
Taste what matters is the Taste yeah
taste taste taste okay you want to say a
little prayer before no no no no I'm a
Believer you're a Believer okay good
luck my man thank you it looks dry it
looks
[Applause]
dry God dear BL you what a nerve on that
Al Murray eh I'll see it's only better
better putting you know yeah you
wouldn't like that would you I wouldn't
mind no cuz it's not Posh food is it I
don't eat only Posh food you do I don't
if I'm if I'm drunk I'll eat anything
but when you're drunk you don't you wake
up in the morning you don't know what
you've eat you don't really care
substance yeah but it's the same way you
wake up in the morning next to Edina
Curry and the wrappings of a Donna cab
oh Christ which is worse the Kebab yeah
you're a gentleman I'm a restaurant
critic I eat only in the finest
restaurants I know what food I'm eating
I know where it's farmed I know how it
gets to my plate I don't accept anything
less unless I'm drunk and then Licensing
Laws change people are going to be drunk
all night there's going to be nothing
else open and they'll make the same kind
of decision as me more and more which is
the terrible one of eating a Donna Kebab
there you go and so we have a first in
the annals of food history Adonna Kebab
purchased Stone Cold Sober I've got to
say I didn't know that it looked like
that in fact I didn't know that it smelt
like that I think before I eat another
one of these I'm going to have to find
out exactly what goes into it I've got
to find out at the very least if it's
even
meat
now of course some Kebab shops make
their own kebabs but most get them from
a factory like this one in Burton on
Trent the idea of kebab and Factory in
the same sentence seems about a bit
wrong I don't eat food from factories
very often I have no idea what kind of
terrible things go on in there the kind
of missing rooms I've heard make me feel
sick but I am going to go and have a
look 700 million are sold in the UK each
year and this Factory alone produces 50
tons of Kebab meat every week but meat
can mean all sorts of horrible things
and I'm hoping Dominic jol the quality
assurance manager here can tell me EX
exactly what we're all eating my word
look at that look at that it's it's uh
it's real meat it's like a Brer shop I
had no idea that anything even
resembling part of an animal went into a
kebab as you can see here they're
trimming up all lamb breast right and
the lamb breast is not being used by
supermarkets or restaurants because very
small because there's not a high demand
for it as you can see bit fatty bit
fatty very finicky to get you know nice
chunks of meat out of and the fact that
this stuff would normally just get
thrown away ends up in a Don Kebab
that's a good thing and is at the end of
of the story what else there other
carcasses there is other trim as well
I'll show you we also use land fronts
and shoulders what happens is with these
the supermarkets sell the lamb cutlets
and the legs lovely kind CH loins in
there isn't it would these are what you
call the neck end God there's a neck
fets though you can eat them nicely well
what we do with these we take these out
and we sell these as Shish I am getting
closer to eating Adon cab sober I think
mhm this it's I say it's very very good
quality
product so uh what have we got here this
is slightly different these are frozen
fellows what's that this is beef
actually this is beef well that's it
because some of our customers we do do a
lam and beef products right and would
you would would would a customer in the
street know whether it's no they
probably wouldn't do somebody who knows
their kebabs would do yeah because with
someone like me who's very finicity
about the kind of meat that I eat lamb
it's very limited to how intensively you
can Farm it everyone's you know
reasonably safe with that beef want you
know the beef Market is slightly
different post BSE and everything and
people are bit more worried about eating
beef it's odd that they would eat it
without knowing well they would have to
know because on a kebab shop they should
declare it if it says Donna Kebab it's a
lamb if it says Kebab then it might be
lamb and beef Ah that's a crucial
distinction to know it's got to say
Donna if it doesn't say Donna it could
be anything this is where all the spices
and herbs are Blended oh get away HS of
spices in in a Don a kebab we have salt
garlic oregano uh
coriander cor that's incredible isn't it
that sounds like Gordon Ramsey at
characteres that's the poest thing I've
ever heard the Don cab turns out to be a
gouro production that's thank you that's
that's that's
fascinating this is where we make all
the handmade doners and where the ones
that come pumped out on the machine are
finished off you're the dawn of the
doners the king of the cabs yeah the
shake of shees how long does it take to
make one of these these Whoppers 5
minutes 5 minutes you're a real artist
then I mean I don't think Gordon Ramsey
could do a thing like this it's lovely
stuff do you ever do you ever sort of
Nick a bit and eat it as your no I don't
eat you're not hungry You' had breakfast
and you can eat it you can eat it but
not room with it but that's all right
yeah nice so yeah I don't think it would
fly out of the shops
you what the skin first no no B first
meat small small that size yeah you have
to measure it like I measure in my mind
that's exactly the right size so I need
too big no really you think my balls are
getting a little bit too big or to one
is small one is Big it doesn't much one
small one big but that does happen on we
go is that finished or do I put another
one on you got to finish all them menu
have I yeah oh have I oops that's you m
of the true look at that look at that we
have to put this one in museum but you
certainly wouldn't want to put in your
[Music]
mouth so here we are then the first
Donna Kebab ever built by a restaurant
critic as I
suspected is fantastic and having you
seen what goes into it I have to say I
wouldn't probably serve this kind of
meat at my own table but you know what
at least it's
meat I tell you what Al it's not just
kebabs that jles Corin eats when he's
drunk you know that last time we came to
my restaurant we had to tell him the
next day what he had for dinner you're
joking he got so pissed he phoned up the
next day to sort of be told what he had
the night before that's fantastic
outrageous yeah absolutely bloody food
critics it's the Moment of Truth the
bread and butter
puddings does yours look
dry look at that
first beautiful huh and mine's not
finished yet Al oh of course it isn't no
no no
but it's a little glaze you know that
yeah apricot jam let down with some
water is that it that's beautiful that
is perfect God dear dear are you going
to dust yours with IC and sugar or
something no no no I I can leave mine
alone serious you can't play with all
that can be possibly done with the bread
and butter pudding genre here Gordon
okay John Baptist yes take the egg
sandwich upstairs and take my bread and
butter pudding alongside it please yes
yeah and make sure you got some sick
bags for the
sandwich next on the menu which is the
winner my wonderful bread and butter
pudding or our bread sandwich time for
the result and the winner
is and I join Marty McCutchen for coffee
I don't do journalists you don't do
journalist oh no you do
shfs
yeah welcome back now to me a very
crucial time CU it's now the time to
find out which dessert is the winner is
it my delicious Sam bread and butter
pudding or is it that sort of sliced
white bread egg sandwich of Al m is
pretty obvious isn't
it the moment it's important that the
pudding judges know what they're talking
about so I tested the pallets of our
diners as they
arrived the ones who could recognize
different flavors will go on to choose
which dessert is best they're
blindfolded so they're only assessing
the food by taste a lucky break for Al
if his was judged by looks it would be
disqualified straight away I want you to
identify these combinations first
combination ready B open wide and in and
open wide please what is in there what
that t on I don't I don't know what that
is at all what's the fruit first you
should know what that
is
MHM beef got your hands is it a
fish what's that taste on something
fruity anyway roast pork roast pork with
apple with apple well
done so that is what that's
um
horrible was that it was really chewy
and bouny like um like a slug or
something half a spoon
M had that with my Sushi last night so
that is what row well
done now open wide
m m lovely M okay here we go I can taste
strawberries no not strawberries
Tomatoes thank God you said that some
kind of grass grass I don't know Che and
taste and I don't really like it or oh
it's bit peppermint would you like to
smoke it is get confus what does it
smell of come on Dorothy definitely
seafood seafood um salmon and H take it
all in good girl what's that taste off
mozzarella mhm good well done what does
it tomato tomato what's the green
leaf Basel well done well done well done
well
done the ones who got most Foods right
became our pudding judges let's see what
they think
[Music]
this is thist dish number one thank you
fruy soft you don't like it no this is
dish number two that's much nicer yeah
that is there's a real difference real
difference you can actually smell it as
well the other one was a bit too
soggy the Moment of Truth has has
finally
[Applause]
arrived there is one winner of course
there's one winner and the winner is
is what doing
then get
out Justice fantastic are you sure they
found your too heavy actually they found
mine too heavy yes
indeed that can't be true I'm afraid it
is
Gordon you know when you go outside this
door and turn left by the traffic lights
it's called a job center really yeah
dear oh dear now I can't believe that Al
monstrosity is going to be served in my
[Applause]
[Music]
restaurant here we are J oh my
word good God what's that when am I
getting pudding it's bread and butter
pudding you didn't eat it no it was it
was very sweet and and and it was you
know what you w after sun Savory but it
was a bit gloopy and it wasn't very warm
and I and i' and I don't like currents
anyway and I got more currents than
anyone or whatever they are you're quite
a fruss pot when it comes to food I kind
of like to avoid Dairy if
possible um and I like to avoid um bread
bread yeah why just cuz it makes me blow
and I don't feel good in my skinny jeans
I'm still fascinated um finally just to
just to almost in my own mind understand
why you weren't taught how to cook
um well my mom did attempt it um a
couple of times and after 4 hours of
peeling a potato and then ending up with
about that much cuz that's what was left
peel it away from that yeah and she just
went off for God's sake and chopped it
in the rubbish and that was that and um
I think that some people are just
naturally gifted at it and I'm not I'm
no good at it if there's one perfect
thing you'd love to learn how to cook
what would it be a roast dinner a roast
dinner yeah I'd love to be able to cook
a roast dinner that's one thing that I
always love to lamb beef um probably
beef beef and I want to do really lovely
York puddings but there you go roast
potatoes oh yeah yeah oh yeah I will
come around and show you how to cook the
perfect Sunday lunch okay will you
really absolutely definitely but where
do I get my sauce spins and frying pan
from first you got nothing of that in
the kitchen I've got my tray in the oven
still unused with the instructions in it
that's how I've never used the oven I
don't even know switching up on I will
bring all that with me okay roasting
tray pots pans sausage you name it I'll
bring China plates as long as you
promise me one thing after I've gone you
continue doing it okay all right minimum
once a month no minimum once a month
once a month okay once a month we cook
yeah should we shake on it kiss on
it promise yes what minimum I'll Supply
everything you get in that kitchen and
cook all right
yeah
so what do you think J it's that a
wallpaper past no it's not that's true
I've never put up any wallpapers I
wouldn't know you wouldn't know you've
never work done a days and is this work
in your life is this grilled or is this
just allowed to go stale no it's you see
my grandmother made this she was an an
Austrian lady she lik the Crunch and
when did you make it 1943 now you're
beginning to upset me you're on the
verge of insulting my family what always
happy with restaurant criticism it turns
out no cuz your grandmother was a great
woman yes she certainly was and she
endured the blitz to give you this
recipe in your time youve kissed the
most amazing guys yeah H Grant and Ross
Kemp and M um there's one sort of knobby
Noom mates around here somewhere um
would you ever kiss jles Corin I don't
know who that is um he's a food critic
um writes of the times oh he's over
there the one with a sort of hairy face
if you saw him he's sort of helping Coes
he's a journalist and he's single I
don't do journalists you don't do
journalists oh no do you do
chefs
yeah yeah
do and one last request that okay I've
never seen a sort of girl serve you know
tea the way you did down the street oh
my God beautiful beautiful bid you send
us thank you just before we go we've had
the stuff we've had the L we've had the
pudding I want you to help John Baptist
just on a few tables serve some coffee
you Ser like a proper wait I want to see
what you like naturally if you can
actually go around the tables with c
yeah I know but that's not really me
I've never been a waitress in my life
watching you yeah serve teas and coffee
is going to give me an insight to what
it's like going around your kitchen
coming around I'll give an open but I've
got high heels on I'll just
about just a couple of tables want to
watch me yes welcome to the FW it's not
rude it's
food on the menu tonight I'm cooking a
delicious seasonal three course meal and
every dish is something you can cook at
home I face my toughest critic yet my
mom she reckons her apple pudding is
better than mine it's nice working
together Gordon don't get used to it cuz
it's not happen
in and the last time Joan Collins was in
my restaurant I threw her out time to
bury the hatchet that's a very polite
way of
being my dad one all never had the the
CU my mother and my dad that I love my
mother and I love my dad want to have
all of
never good
evening okay s an ready ready yes Ronnie
ready yes for me the most important
table is the first yes that starts to
tell you what kind of evening we in for
and we're in for what evening a fabulous
a fabulous evening okay six covers table
15 six Rosato six monfish six
desserts thank you let's go all right
three three and three yes here we go
we're back in the fword restaurant and
between now and Christmas each and every
week we're cooking for 60 special
invited guest a delicious three course
dinner this week's all about pumpkins
and bumi parties and now the prop have
gone back it's all about warm hearty
classy comfort
food so for the start of this evening
I'm cooking the most amazing delicious
pumpkin risoto finished with wild rocket
to give that really nice peppery flavor
risoto how long 30 seconds 30 seconds
yes that means together 30 seconds guys
yes yeah so a lot of people are scared
of cooking Roso at home but you know
it's an amazing dish to cook and once
you've cracked it it's so
versatile Pumpkin we're using the
pumpkin flesh in two ways first is to
make a puree for the risotto to ensure
we bring out the best flavor but we also
keep some of the pumpkin to one side we
dice it finely and we'll add this to the
dish later on to give it texture and
bite make the puree by sweating down the
roughly diced pumpkin in a little olive
oil and butter this evaporates the water
in the pumpkin and intensifies the
flavor why not use a lid good question
if I put lid on that now it's going to
cause all the Steam and water to go in
there I've left it cond I've left it
vaporized around here so the steam can
come out I don't want it watery you put
lid on that now You' just got a watery
pumpkin tin fall in the center keep the
heat in and pure is quicker okay good
now the Pumpkin we're going to puree now
yeah so we're not going to drain it off
his juices or anything stupid like that
all we're going to do now is take it off
the stove and put it into a blender if
we do it now where it's nice and hot
it'll get nice and fine if you left it
to cool down lumpy it'll go lumpy
exactly
that okay 30 seconds and then
watch a real nice smooth puree pumpkin
puree sweat the onion in olive oil until
lightly colored add the risoto rice and
cook for a couple of minutes then add
stock until the grains start to swell
stock so pumpkin
puree mix it in now it's starting to
boil the rice is opening up okay Y and
the most important thing is now we start
seasoning a little bit with Parmesan y
yeah
now we've put our second level of
pumpkin in yeah our roasted pumpkin
yeah okay put our rocket in as well y
okay and now we're going to finish it
with some butter but we don't boil it
with the butter in we work the butter in
look at the rice you can just see a
little touch it's a bit bigger now yeah
no but see the center the the center of
the rice the grain is bright white it's
got a little bit of bite to it yeah
always look for that little white bit in
the center of the rice the grain yeah
when you can't see that forget it bin it
okay let's go now when it goes on the
plate look it should relax on there
nicely wait let's just check we got even
portions on there yeah now follow me
with my hands plate Shake in all the
corners there you go nice and flat right
parmesan follow me on and sprinkle it
over nicely open it up good two or three
little fried Sage leaves on top don't
snap them in half and then finally your
Sage butter over the top over the
top right are you happy with
that are you happy with that yes you are
yeah right good table please my come's
happy but what about our diners the
starter was actually I've got to say
really nice once I got tucked into it
but I didn't like the smell of it I
thought it smelled a bit odd I don't
know whether I order it again but I'm
glad I had it good color very bright
yellow canary I like that brilliant
fantastic really nice really
hello Mom glad you make it good to see
you you well yeah it was very nice how
was the Roto lovely yeah nice and light
nice lovely flavor yes very good not too
salty no no no pumpkin this time of year
absolutely perfect perfect yeah you can
make something like that quite easily
could you yes I could yes yes I'm going
to see you later for pudding okay yes
I'm not too sure who however thank you
thank you it's a big night as well as my
mom Joan Collins is back in my
restaurant for the first time in 7 years
she'd come in with a food critic would
really upset me and he threw them both
out hello how are you I'm
fine I'm very on thank you can I just
say good to see you it's good to see you
and congratulations on this place looks
fabulous first of all I've got something
very important to say to you I wonder
what that would be i' just like to say a
big apology oh because my mother that
dear lady sat over there has never
forgiven me on the back of me asking you
to leave my restaurant what
sorry well it's okay Gordon listen it's
a long time ago I'm I don't bear grudges
but I think the media had a lot to do
with blowing it up they loved that story
I mean it was in all the papers the man
who threw Joan Collins out of his
Resturant can I just say you're welcome
in all of my resturants anytime you like
thank you D to ask you um what are your
pet hates in restaurants what do you
load more I was at a restaurant the
other night that shall be nameless and
every time the the food came out the um
the the chef would come out and
announces the food and announces How
It's Made and everybody has to stop
talking which you know I was in the
middle of telling it rather amusing
anecdote I thought but um that's one of
my are you a fussy eater because I don't
eat that much I really want everything
that I eat to be really really good so
therefore if I order you know some
chicken and the chicken is too hard I
won't send it back but I won't eat it
which is an insult to a chef clearly
there's something wrong with it so
that's a very polite way of being a
oh is it well just not eating it
Gordon I don't want to eat food that
doesn't doesn't taste right to me and
get fat with eating something thank you
I'm a little exhausted cuz I've been
working very hard on football as wise
I've heard yes which is a hoop you're
going to be doing any sort of Saucy um
sort of sexy SC because hey oh you're
bloody good at that thank you um you
don't need to rehearse that and um
something I'm getting really excited
about
I don't well that's sort ofish M I could
say I think they've turned it down a bit
but it is still a bit it's quite soury
but I'm working a lot with Zoe Lucker
who plays Tanya Tucker who's the the
and I'm a surprise surprise
so we are the two we really are the two
biggest that we've ever
seen next on the
menu along with our main course of
monkfish and muscles my campaign to get
women back in the kitchen goes full
steamer ha better than anything I've
cooked ever 52 days till Christmas and
my turkeys are still Goblin but for how
long asley deia Nigella Jamie
Anthony welcome back to the fword the
food show that puts its money where your
mouth is if you'd like to come and eat
here and check out the fword website
Ronnie I want Monkish in a pan yeah I'm
not asking again yeah I want the monk
fish in the pan now
yeah let's go time for the main course
roasted monkfish in the most amazing
muscle
broth now a touch a curry powder makes
the combination warm fragrant and
absolutely delicious here's
[Music]
[Applause]
how monk fish it's quite a difficult
fish to get right because there's a lot
of water M fish curry powder and salt
and the salt starts to extract the water
so when we come to roasting it it
doesn't boil and get a really nice color
on
there leave 5
minutes muscle
broth thyme bay
leaves hot pan
muscles get your lid ready in this hand
white wine
in
now shake
it this turns the muscles around almost
like been putting a tumble dryer so they
cook
evenly 30 seconds and go
[Applause]
look that's Gold Dust shell muscles
lovely look at that look
beautiful
celery
carrots
leaks
garlic saffron salt curry
powder but the secret behind it is that
really nice little pinch of saffron that
gives it that little bit of
lift strain muscle
[Applause]
juice red
[Music]
juuice add
muscles bring it up to the
boil
100 Ms double cream
coriander back to the fish the water has
come
out pat
dry
amazing lovely color the fish is too hot
to slice so if I started slicing all the
goodness will run out of it leave you to
sit in there for about 2 or 3 minutes so
it
relaxes
it's a nice big chunky
slies monkfish with curried muscle
broth
done never ever buy powdered saffron it
may color the food but it won't give any
flavor that's the perfect saffron yellow
tip red tip and a dark Rich red orangey
great for
flavor helping me cook the main course
is my kitchen Brigade so tonight my
Brigade is Ronnie the 6'4 model opposite
Ronnie is the gorgeous an she just come
back from two holiday and God did we
miss her last week every Chef has a
right-and man Mark sergeant again on the
hot plate and then finally our two
commies our trainee carries come all the
way from Liverpool and opposite carry
we've got cam looks like you just come
from a boy band over the course of this
series I'm rot testing two traines each
week in the fword kitchen we call them
com the one that performs the best will
get a job with me C and kery were two
out of the Thousand individuals that
applied to come in this
kitchen I asked the 100 best to come to
London and bring me their signature dish
something that showed me what they knew
about food I haven't slept every night
since I found out I was in because it it
it means a lot it's a personal goal my
first job was to weed out the ones who
are good on paper but crap on the plate
right Elaine Hi how are you fine thank
you now what in the do we have
here that looks like a dog's dinner
thank you yeah where are the puppies
you're at home right it looks like
you've cut someone's dick off wrapped in
a condom be honest they do look like dog
balls don't they oh my God okay okay
what I'm looking for here today is
Passion enthusiasm and understanding of
ingredients
right um what happened there I know it's
called the f word but when it's brown
it's cook when it's black it's um and
there's a like pubic hair though you
just get rid of that sorry yeah there we
go now but look at them you smell like
ammonia in there yeah little bit there
Skol all right I see you're on the verge
of killing someone I wasn't trying to
kill him although that would have made
the headlines I would have become famous
that way uh the guy who saw off Gordon
Ramsey I'm a vegan I've been a vegan for
20 years you're a vegan yes me how can
you call yourself a chef you don't cook
fish or meat well I work in vegetarian
restaurants and what is it um this is a
Cory tofu with a tofu
yogurt
sorry it wasn't just talent I was
looking for I wanted passion too stoy
drove for 5 hours to get her dish to me
rice vinegar Wasabi I hope you don't
mind the
kick that works that's very good
I'm
speechless how are you Phil started off
washing dishes in a Liverpool restaurant
8 O do breast cooked off to Ping yep
well you're 19 years of age um I know
about a dozen 29y old chefs that can't
cook that good yeah to work in Gordon's
restaurant it would mean a lot be a
massive honor um I'd get a lot of
experience hopefully he can teach me
everything he knows and when I'm looking
for new members of Staff um I want to
see that hunger and you can see at the
back of their eyes you know you can
really feel their sort of you know
ambition their determination I want to
be g's po show because I cuz I know I
can throw my kitchen within car just
stand back two seconds what in the have
we got on I'm sorry not very well H are
you it's done beautifully okay thank you
and like I said you can tell there's a
lot of sort of care yeah cuz you're very
precious of what you do yeah the way you
dress the way you look thanks very much
the fact you haven't got a bloody spot
on your face pisses me off not a wrinkle
a dimple or anything are you sure you
want to become a chef yeah I'd really
like to are you
mad getting through the interview
process was the easy bit now the
question for my comies is will they
stand the heat of the
kitchen I want you to slow down I'd
rather you be slower and thorough and
fast and scatty okay cuz right now
you're making me feel nervous at the
moment I'm feeling stressed out uh can
we light this back stove please uh
an good and turn it around yeah put on
the stuff here please now I want six in
there an what's he
doing I can't speak any more plain
English but you I don't know what's
going on at the moment M can you do it
please yeah there put that pan in the
oven put that pan to wash and get four
more in there the atmosphere in the
kitchen is very hot very
stressful but still
enjoyable spinach
please right Carrie come here Carrie I
want you plating
up Ronnie I want four more away now an
four more away go to the furthest plate
please thank
you good watch watch first two nice bits
of monkfish on top of the spinach one
nugget on top three yes take your time
don't panic stand still and go please
very nice yeah well done go 15
slowly
the sauce was really nice it's a curry
sauce I understand so you could kind of
sense the spices in the sauce coming out
of the fish and it went nicely together
with the muscles as well put this on the
menu cuz it's fantastic and I'd have a
little go up mucking about trying to
trying to get I'll even have a look
through some of the governor's books to
see if there's a you know a recipe for
that cuz I I would I do that a dinner
party manic manic manic right I bet
you'd never ever thought you'd see Joe p
rest again I I never thought I'd see any
woman in one of your restaurants again
what do you mean upset them he's upset
them so much with this campaign to get
women back in the kitchen it's been in
the papers in Australia and Korea really
yeah and all they care about you thought
they cared about you know freedom from
communism no what they care about is you
and your your evil C pain the message
was of course was not only to get women
back in the kitchen but to sort of make
it less of a chore make them understand
that you know it's it can be pleasurable
easy simp easy simple I'm not trying to
get women back in the kitchen that don't
want to be there you I'm trying to you
know get women in the kitchen that are
excited and interested in food as
opposed to sort of tiptoeing over it and
investing in a readymade meal the
infamous survey which you had
commissioned one of the things was
wasn't it was that the women who they
couldn't cook two-thirds of them were
regretted the fact they couldn't cook
and also they're not being taught it no
one's taught in schools anymore no one
knows a basic thing like how to make a
soup or anything like that you know it's
not off it's off the curriculum you know
it's ridiculous so many women have
actually missed out on the opportunity
of learning and that's the crisis the
ones that have sort of N I don't want to
learn how to cook you know I'm 21 move
the clock forward 10 years and they
start to deeply regret the fact that
they don't know how to cook and
completely and this is really honestly
petrified of the stove Jim and I had
decided to get married and um so we'd
invited our respective parents around to
meet each other for the first time the
one I remember was this big fish pie
that's sort of become sort of slightly
legendary it was just fish slop is what
it was you needed a straw did have a
sort of detrimental effect on her
confidence in the kitchen maybe and you
know the fact that she's not cooked
again in 9 years probably probably bears
that hour say you know obviously cuz I'm
a doctor I'm
always pontificating to patients about
the sorts of diets they should be eating
she gives out a few lectures to the to
her punters about uh you know eat five
bits of fruit and veggie a day or
whatever and I I've never seen a
vegetable in her hands hello good
morning Hi how are you fine
thanks
kitchen that is what I use for the whole
time for my food sausages with mash
sausages with mash and this is a
readymade meal this is basic sausage of
mash yeah but the whole thing's full of
readymade meals but you're a GP I know
yeah with a phenomenal reputation yeah
that gets to see patients each and every
day then helps coming up with remedies
to make them feel better and better
about themselves how can you do that
with a freezer packed full of readymade
meals it's completely hypocritical cuz I
know what what is in in those meals Is
Not Great most important thing now is
not just about your um confidence yeah
it's about doing something that you can
easily put together y cocka van it's
just like a really nice red wine sort of
chicken casserole excellent very simple
great fny today we're going to put some
lons bacon what Ladon bacon yeah that's
bits of bacon onions mushrooms as it
gets more and more into the winter you
can put sweed in there carrots in there
leaks in there to serve with a cocka van
just a really nice straightforward
creamy mashed potato lovely how many's
coming around uh three plus me and Jim
so five five so that's enough for five
that size all we've done now is seasoned
the chicken with salt and pepper lightly
dusted it with flour and when we put the
flour on there it helps give it color
and it starts to thicken the casserole
shake off excess flour okay and then
just into olive oil the more color Yeah
the more flavor yeah good I want you to
fry off okay the
lons
good now tablespoon of olive oil in
there again I want you to get your
onions in there this time so they need
to be chopped today no we're going to
put them in hole I think okay yeah we
don't mess around with chopping onions
tan nice and hot right okay and
mushrooms in yes push towards you I'm
going to pull back wait what I want to
do now is Place half of our mushrooms
and bacon on the bottom
chicken back into the
casserole and all I've got here is a
cheap bottle of um house wine right yeah
yeah because for cooking wine you don't
need to use expensive wine no so now
we're bringing the heat back up I want
you to pick off some of these time
flowers just sprinkle them over there
like that okay y good I add my hot water
into the stock got the bay leaves in
there turn the gas
off lid on then want it to go into the
oven okay okay for 30 35 minutes yeah
nice and low and everything else is
self-explanatory just to make sure it's
not cooking too fast cooking too slow
and sort of you know treat it bit like
your patients yeah give them the
prescription and you want to know in a
couple of weeks time how they're feeling
feel the same way for your chicken now I
imagine this is going to be pretty high
cuz it's the first time I've been close
to a woman in a kitchen all afternoon
that hasn't cooked for 10 years good
news or bad news it's good news it's
good news go on got great blood pressure
any
recommendations um eat plenty of fresh
food and vegetables oh no
pre-prepared crap you know stay away
from the freezer right absolutely yeah
yeah tonight after 9 years Helen's
parents and in-laws are back to sample
her cooking Quick Check okay final check
and then just get the spoon yeah and
sort of push it back down underneath
okay right so you ready for this this is
cocko van with mashed po yeah I can't
believe it I'm go smack I'm amazing it's
great fantastic happy with the
chicken she melting in the mouth this is
better than anything I've cooked ever
good night good night well done thank
you and next time I see you I'll keep
that blood pressure down yeah
yes hello doctor hello how are you I'm
check that pulse pulsating at a rate of
1,000 mph oh calm down a bit calm down
calm down I heard that before Jim how
are you very well thanks good to see you
nice to see you okay first and crucial
question y was I successful in
conquering that phobia about cooking a
resonating yes the very next day
truthfully the very next day very next
day we had six people around for dinner
I mean I made about you know half a ton
and it was all eaten how was it it was
great it was like a a mixed grill with
lots of vegetables and fish and uh some
um ccus cuscus yeah it was delicious it
was it was great and I got a real burth
out of doing it and sitting him down
pouring glass of wine fantastic I'm so
happy and have you any idea over the
last 10 days I've been getting so much
stick about getting women back in the
kitchen I think that's I think that's
rubbish you know I mean what the stick
or the campaign no the stick the stick
you know I mean I I just think that over
the last kind of 15 20 years women have
sort of been forgotten about um the
enjoyment they maybe can get from the
kitchen and whilst I've been doing this
and obviously I've been talking to
people about it those are people have
kind of come out as non- cookers of
women they said to me oh God Helen I I
can't cook either I am so happy
congratulations promise me you won't
stop I won't I won't otherwise this
heartbeat pulse is going to shoot back
to yeah I don't want that because Che
right next on the menu is pudding time
and would you believe m mom yes blesser
cotton socks actually still thinks that
her apple is better than mine we'll find
out in a minute and Joan Collins gives
me tips on looking young big question do
you think I need
Botox welcome back to the fword now
tonight yes my M and I are going
actually going to go head-to-head with
our Apple puddings and you know all
about my campaign about getting women
back in the kitchen well the first woman
I ever saw in the kitchen was my mom and
for some bizarre reason yes against my
21 years experience in a professional
kitchen she still reckons that her apple
pudding is better than mine just a
woman's thing a woman's thing well um
I'm going to wish you good luck because
I think you're going to need it how
long's going it take you need it 20
minutes 20 minutes I'll see you in the
oven right okay good luck and no spying
we're both making apple puddings mine's
a new Twist on Eve's pudding and for Mom
I'm not sure what she's doing but it
does have apples in it now Mom what's it
like being in my kitchen as opposed to
yours not much different no don't you
think mine's a little bit cleaner no it
is not don't a chicken so there's no set
recipe to yours then right no I used to
make it at least once a week when you're
a little boy right I'm actually doing an
ease pudding bit of a classic ease
pudding we're peeling these brayburn
apples we're going to cut the apples
into quarters and then actually
caramelize them in a little bit of
butter once they caramelize in bit
butter got rid of the water out the
Apple we're going to sort of dlay with
some Calvados uh mom yes how you doing
I'm fine do you want your hand no let's
see what you're doing
and in there I got my currents yeah here
I got my apples I just peeled the apples
going take out the Coes then I'm going
to well I don't want you looking at too
much yeah no no no well otherwise in
case you start getting a little bit more
you done this why almonds there look
that's almonds yeah almonds I'm going to
put the almonds on top do you know the
traditional recipe for leaves ping
hasn't got your fruit soaked in it and
it hasn't got almonds no what I'm trying
to do Mom is a bit of a modern day
version you I mean huh not the kind of
thing you take down the bingo hle
there's nothing wrong with Tak it in the
Bingle hole look what is that this is an
old deia Smith's recipe of Eve's pudding
right yes Julia doesn't put whole
alcohol on her fruit no okay and she
doesn't use fruit it's just apples in
the sponge okay well normally de saes
her alcohol for half
time is that not too high no it's not
too high Mom that's fine the fire alarm
will go off dear dear it's nice to have
you back in the kitchen again yeah it's
nice working together other Garden yeah
yeah don't get used to it cuz it's not
happening again no I know yeah all right
good right tell me what you're doing in
yours I'm just going just through mine
pastry um you've put at the bottom of
the dish will that work of course it
does yeah all right I'm just asking
don't get ay dear here you don't have to
swear no Mom covers her apples with a
merang topping while I cover mine with a
light sponge mixture using flour eggs
sugar Calvados and the zest of a
lemon and we pour this mixture on top
top of the apples and bake in the oven
for about 12 to 15 minutes but before we
put in the oven we get some um almonds
some M and sugar dust it so as it starts
to bake in the oven it caramelizes with
this really nice almond texture on top
right Mom how you doing there you are Mr
Ramsey bring it over here please yes
next to
mine do you know what Mom I got a really
good feeling about this one you know
that what for me no no no but for me you
know H I think for me huh look at the
difference and this is payback time for
all that gray lamb you served me for
those years the moment of truth yes
ladies first thank you okay truth is in
the eating of the
pudding okay there you go good luck good
luck cuz I think you're going to need it
no I think you'll need
it okay good right then the chef's
challenge you were beaten last week uh
what about your mom well first of all I
don't like losing you know I hate losing
you know how competitive I am bit weird
having your mom in the kitchen that's
where it all started from that's the
first woman I ever saw in a kitchen was
her so bit spooky but however you know
she's fine leaving that aside how's
Christmas dinner coming along sadly bit
of bad news um Gary recently has being
sick as a pat so um and Gary's the one
with the funny little spiky hair that's
the one with the sort of spiky hair
that's constantly got his back up and
always on the defense When de is having
a poke so well let's hope he pulls
through let's hope he pulls through you
getting the vet in yeah I'm going to get
the vet in um not just on the absess on
Gary's foot but um the speculation on
bird flu just want to make sure a are we
covered B what measures should we take
to make sure sure they're not affected
by that quite a
worry let
just okay okay we'll get up okay we'll
get up okay and Meg make sure daddy
makes me a cup of tea you're so lazy
okay let's go thank you I want you guys
cleaning it out fresh water really yes
well of course we got to help clean
right Jack and Holly you get the water
Matilda yeah you start clearing out this
one in here please
yes I'll open the gate it's a very
special Christmas for us this year we've
got the six turkeys the children have
responsibility of fattening them up for
the Christmas table and really learning
all about it and where our food comes
from asley deia Nigella Jamie Anthony
Gary Gary's been unwell for the last
couple of days and there's a problem
with his foot so um I'm slightly
concerned about it I'm going to get hold
of the vet and actually find out what
the problem is morning Peter morning
thank you for coming down that's fine
pleasure like Cris is on her
hand Gary's been limping so he's been
sort of coming in and out of the pen but
sort of hopping can you pick him up for
me that
possible this is an abscess here in the
bottom of his foot oh really this is
called bumblefoot um he's got an
infection in the base of his foot here I
think at the moment it's probably
worthwhile just keeping an eye on that
because it may settle down on its own
and obviously these are food birds so we
don't want to load them with lots of
antibiotic the other concern of course
was um Aven flu sure um should I be
concerned about it I think we've got to
be concerned but here in this
environment your risks are quite low so
the kids are in here two three times a
day um what's the sort of most important
rule for them well the catch word here
is biocurity the the contamination for
these birds is going to be from either
from the wild or from you bringing
contamination in so it's very important
really to have sets of wellingtons for
the children to wear that they just wear
for in here sure um if you if you go out
and you're out in an area where there's
wild fowl you could be walking through
duck Pooh Y and and you could bring that
contamination back in again um they need
to wash their hands each time they've
handle the birds we're under the
impression that droppings are the main
threat really and uh I think it's very
important that you cover this area so
that these birds are not not having
their area contaminated with bird
droppings no thank you Peter no problem
L this way down walk down that's it not
the world's greatest
DIY let take my
way he fall on one of them they already
be dead before
Christmas hold this end down here please
ni right Holly Daddy it's not coming
here you go Daddy I can't hold it any
longer okay I'm just coming give me two
seconds okay quick
hold it hold on to it l Jack what are
you doing
jack oh
see now they're covered
up we're keeping the turkeys out of the
wet and bringing down the risk of any
possible Avan
flu not bad let's keep the area nice and
dry now yes right um
hey hands washed Well's off let's
go
hi Peter hello everyone how are you I'm
very well thank you just like a bit of
an update really um bit of bad news Gary
well the only thing we do I had to look
in this morning uh and he is still lame
so we put him on antibiotics antibiotics
yeah and he's going to be on those for a
week how long will that stay in his
system we have to leave 8 Days clear so
you got plenty of time really uh
unfortunately if he stays lame we may
have to say goodbye to him I'm afraid
what do you mean say goodbye actually
kill him yeah poor Gary but we'll get
him on antibiotics and hopefully that
will do the trick Peter thank you all
right good to see you take care take
care okay wait wait wait now there's
mine now again I have to say
presentation wise
yeah yours looks nice but doesn't blo me
away however cooked in the middle is
that cooked in the middle
yeah no oh
um no it's not actually all right smart
ass uh 2 minutes please how do you know
that wasn't cooked in the middle from my
angle you can see it sinking in the
middle
Titanic while my sinking dessert
finishes cooking Three Blind tasters
chosen from this evening's diners are
waiting to pick a
winner there we go thanks for waiting
they both look lovely don't they they do
look nice but I think mine just looks a
little bit better
okay Johan Baptist wait here we go
yeah good luck thank you not bad give me
kiss this is pudding number
one oh that's very nice it tastes like
um you know Brandy butter that you have
with Christmas pudding that's what it
tastes like to me actually some that
pastri is a bit dry I didn't usually
like raisins but I quite like these I
think because I can taste bit all jokes
apart do you actually think you're going
to win yes I do yeah you do yeah yeah
putting number two thank you well it's
completely different very sweet very
very sweet little bit too sweet for my
taste actually I I much prefer this one
actually okay guys it's time for results
so I'm going to start with you Stephen
number one was my preference okay thank
you number two was my favorite and
finally jacn pudding number one or
pudding number two number one number one
thank you guys good thank you and the
winner
is excellent I'm John
Baptist how can you do that to my mom
you French Frank if that was your mom
there I would have made her win I would
have choose I would have choose anyway
seriously I think I thinken yours is
better than Gordon anyway I'd never one
had you not taught me properly you know
that see so is your fault that's the
secret yeah that's the secret I knew
there was something in
it hello
and D to ask you do you cook at home of
course yes what was the last me you cook
I cooked together with my husband Percy
yeah a roast chicken loads of olive oil
loads of garlic and loads of onions and
we have that just with some broccoli or
I like um mushy peas and does Percy ever
cook does yes he cooks too he loves to
cook breakfast in bed maybe yeah we do
that I understand him totally because
he's my age yes so it must be a massive
thing for him cooking and fulling this
breakfast for you going upstairs to the
bedroom and then you send the bacon back
cuz it's not crispy enough oh no and we
don't have bacon in bed no breakfast in
bed will usually be croissant or toast
or orange juice and coffee the only
thing that I don't eat is junk food no I
I couldn't eat a hamburger or a hot dog
or uh what are those things with holes
in a
donut I couldn't eat one of those to
save my life you'd make a great female
chef you know that balls of steel no no
I would no no no no I would not cuz I
can't stand you know and it gets really
hot and all the pots and pans and all
that thing I can't do that pressure you
handle brilliantly and you take the
pressure as healthy because you're still
at it yeah what would you suggest to get
me looking sort of less craggy less
wrinkled what would you I don't think
you look cracky and wrinkled at all I
mean you're what 40 38 38 okay do you
think I need Botox I think Botox is
poison and I think that they have not
yet discovered how seriously it can
affect people if there one thing that
you would ask me to teach you in the
kitchen what would it be how to make a
great omelet ah yes I love omelettes and
they're very very hard to make if You'
be so kind I would love to show you how
to make an omelette in 2 minutes
downstairs and I just love to show you
something that you can turn around said
yeah haed little schmu s years ago
however no I didn't hate you Life's too
short to hate would you be so kind I'll
just show you an omelette and that would
just a make my day and B okay keep my
mom happy my back let's do it thank you
I'm dying to see be good I'm dying to
see what you think
of just watch the stairs ddy all right
why don't you go first there we go um
and cooking an omelette is actually
quite sort of straightforward and I
think the secret is to make sure to make
sure we don't have too much
color too much what color so just sort
of a little bit sort of light brown on
the outside okay yeah light brown but I
like it very very soft inside very soft
yeah really runny okay great
hi guys let's come over here like that
stove for me please this is Joan hello
apron please okay I'm just just so I
don't Splash you oh it's it's one of my
things there we go oh la la there we go
baby and round how Chic and that's it
nice and I don't want to Splash
otherwise there we are good right
okay I want to see how you've cracked
your eggs eggs yeah on the side of the
bowl and and just open up your hand see
if I did that that I just have a load of
egg yolks in there practice makes
perfect I mean egg egg egg shells shells
open yes and I'm just praying now I
don't get any
shell you want me to try
sure see I no that's not bad look in
there that's not bad there's no shell in
there oh no there's not you're right
there's no shell in there at all okay
butter in you like to put with butter
rather than Olive Oil um that's a nice
way of do an omelette olive oil you know
that in France they always make the
we always make our hes with olive oil
but we're in London now Joe not Paris
okay I think olive oil is one of the
healthiest things you can eat absolutely
olive oil and garlic can you pour my
eggs in there please
D into the pan thank you use the spatula
ah the spatula and God cuz what it does
it helps to clean the side of the plant
what kind of a saucepan is
this it's a it's an iron saucepan right
yes Skillet as I call yeah know that
word for ages
salt scrambled eggs so far so good no
salt going to do it right now not too
much if I put it in too early it turns
the eggs a little bit gray oh really
little sprinkle of cheese for me a
spoonful of cheese just a spoonful of
cheese and just sprinkle on there pet
knife please this is the exciting part
for me for why has it not turned into
scrambled eggs because I whisked it as
we were cooking it and all I'm going to
do now is just start to fold it and
hopefully it's not going to stick 1 and
1/2 minutes looks great slightly running
yeah that's how I like it I'll be over
the moon you just give me a a little
taste and B a
verdict that's really good really you
had just the right amount of
um cheese in there marks out of 10 oh
definitely 10 10 and is it as good as
Percy's or better it's as good as as
good
as you've been absolute sweetheart thank
you d it's been fun next on the menu
service please my mom teaches me a thing
or two about serving desserts this is
easy peasy is it I don't know why you
got all stressed out about it and how to
get a three course meal for literally
nothing it's a little bit bruised but I
mean
[Applause]
be welcome back just in time for pudding
round we go oh dear how can you have
that moment with your mom huh okay oh
there's not there's not enough string on
the apron oh that was he L I love you
I'm joking I'm joking take the portion
like that and just on top of the creeme
fresh like that but make sure you have
all that nice caramel something you
didn't have in your earase pudding all
right Gordon don't rub it in I know you
don't like shouting I know you don't
like swearing yeah but I want you to
shout a nice big loud service for me
service please no it's not loud enough
no one heard you service please no Mom
you got to say it yeah with a pair of
sort of glies service please service
please that's better thank you table
five table five let's
go okay this is easy peasy is I don't
know why you got all stressed out about
it my mom's happy but are the
diners it was the texture that I
absolutely loved about it just was
perfect for me I thought it was
absolutely gorgeous I love the texture I
thought the nuts on the top were
gorgeous wasn't too sweet but it was
just very very enjoyable light and
perfect to end the meal right what do
you think of dessert uh it was fantastic
you enjoyed it yeah I'd love to have
tasted your mom's I must say yeah but
you're happy for once over the moon yeah
yeah would you have paid for it of
course not of course not right Charles
um when you're not freeloading in
restaurants what else have you been
eating this week when I'm not doing my
job in restaurants eating because I have
to glad the way you call that a job what
have you been doing I this week I've
been eating from dustbins I've been
living the life of a freegan a frean is
a person from a Dustbin from a Dustbin a
frean is a person you would say rather
like me who never pays for their food uh
but they do it by going around the back
door of restaurants sandwich shops
supermarkets and going through the
rubbish which is usually huge amounts of
really good fresh food which gets thrown
away to serve the great capitalist
Beast I'm terribly sorry to take you
away from Gordon's delightful restaurant
and bring you to this revolting stinking
rubbish heat but there's food here too a
third of all the food that we produce in
this country is thrown away and ends up
in a place like this
[Music]
why do we throw so much food away
Society is a lot more picky about
quality supermarkets are very choosy
people won't buy apples when they're
flawed they the wrong shape the wrong
size there's a lot of food waste being
generated through grading perfectly
decent food that uh just never makes it
to the table one of the solutions is to
intercept it between the bin and the
landfill and eat it and that's what
freans do so I'm going to get one of
these freans to help me make a three
course meal meal using food found in
bins it all started I think when I was
um breeding pigs and uh and I realized
my God you didn't eat what the pigs
didn't want to eat no no I didn't eat
what the pigs didn't want to eat I used
to give I used to collect waste food and
give it to the pigs right okay and it
was then that I realized just how much
food was being thrown away every single
day by every single outlet what kind of
bins are we talking about so right what
we have here is a bin of a typical
Central London supermarket and inside
you can be pretty sure there'll be some
food okay so what we have here is a lot
of bananas we have a lot of bananas so
you know it's perfectly good it's what
you'd expect to find on anyone's fruit
table I mean look there's that is that's
packaged but my hands are a bitan it's a
little bit bruised but I
mean nothing wrong with that at all they
see that's the kind of thing you can eat
straight from a bin isn't it well I
suppose so yeah so look trishan the
point is is that with these bins have
not been that promising it's not been a
particularly good time I've got this
this box that I want to fill and do you
think there's any chance that we could
get we go somewhere else to some
slightly upscale
[Music]
bins I really found it's like a
chocolate cheesecake someone's been here
already and left all the bags open do
you shop every day fridge or you bring
it home and put it in the fridge same as
you I go shopping every few days only
instead of going shopping I get it out
of a bin and I'll take it home and I'll
do just what you
do I think you've caught a dud there I
think that's that's a r that's a r c a
dud it takes a certain amount of
expertise apparently up here there's a
place which always leaves loads of
really fine food out so we're uh we're
going we're going h
my God look at that s extraordinary
absolutely full we've got buns we've got
sandwiches got cheese my three meal
let's start off with a possible salad
then that's a starter that go St avocado
and mozzarella salad nice looking
mozzarella okay tuna is that any good
for you I mean this is uh I don't know
if it was line caught dolphin friendly
so I won't touch if you're going to kill
an animal yeah to put it onto a food
shelf the very least you can do is
eating yeah exactly respect it's what
flipper would have wanted so after not
very long rumaging with my Newfound
frean friend I have assembled not just a
meal but a but a banquet Fit For A King
wasn't able to find a table so having a
nice picnic on the grass uh and I'm
going to start my meal with a spot of
sushi I'm going to have a little bit of
uh free soy
sauce the top suits came free okay next
up we got some salad bit of balsamic
vinegar and cheap olive oil that's
perfectly decent I've had worse in in
many a High Street chain Brer for which
I probably paid 7 or8 quid plus service
there's very little service here you
don't have to tip the dustman oh it's
pasta under there very exciting there's
a pasta and cheese salad with a
unidentified Brown thing but you always
get unidentified Brown things even in
Gordon Ramy
restaurants you're watching the nation's
foremost restaurant critic eating
rubbish he's found in bags are sitting
on the floor in a city park no stronger
message could be given about the waste
that is being
thrown that J's corin will do absolutely
anything for a free dinner type
[Music]
bastard